either humans are very special we took a
lot of leaps that arrived at what it
means to be human yeah
um there's a question there which was
the hardest which was the most special
but also if others have reached this
level and maybe many others have reached
this level
the great filter
that prevented them from going farther
to becoming a multi-planetary species or
reaching out into the stars and those
are really important questions for us
whether
um
whether there's other alien
civilizations out there or not this is
very useful for us to think about if we
destroy ourselves
how will we do it and how easy is it to
do yeah well you know these are big
questions and i've thought about these a
lot but the the interesting thing is
that if we're if we're alone
that's somewhat comforting from the
great filter perspective because it
probably means the great filters will be
past
and i'm pretty sure they are so that by
in going back to your origin of life
question there are some incredible
things that no one knows how happened
like obviously the first life form from
chemical soup that seems pretty hard but
i would guess the multicellular i
wouldn't be that surprised if we saw
single level
single cell sort of life forms elsewhere
uh bacteria type things but
multicellular life seems incredibly hard
that step of you know capturing
mitochondria and then sort of using that
as part of yourself you know when you've
just eaten it would you say that's the
biggest
the most uh like
if if you had to choose one sort of uh
hitchhiker's got this galaxy one
sentence summary of like oh those clever
creatures did this that would be the
motives i think that's probably the one
that that's the biggest i mean there's a
great book called the 10 grand great
inventions of evolution by nick lane and
he speculates on 10 10 of these you know
what could be great filters um i think
that's one i think the the advent of of
of intelligence and and conscious
intelligence and in order you know to us
to be able to do science and things like
that is huge as well i mean it's only
evolved once as far as you know uh in in
earth history so that would be a later
candidate but there's certainly for the
early candidates i think multicellular
life forms is huge
you